hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmccontrolat.l2-3.2.3 provides security
awareness training on recognizing and
Reporting
potential indicators of
Insider threat
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling paranoid overwhelmed tired
and alone trying to understand all this
cmmc dfars and nist sp800 171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload I got great news for you you
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance hero all right let's
jump into it so in
cmmccontrolat.l1-3.2.3 I can wrap like
as good as Eminem I just gotta talk
about these controls and like maybe if I
talk about two in a row like I'm there
I'm right there I'm like on like sixth
mile all right provides security
awareness training on recognizing and
Reporting potential indicators of
Insider threat we're looking over our
shoulder we're looking under the desk
not really because there's nothing under
this desk and I'm I'm buying more pants
uh we're looking on the desk so we're
looking around the corner in our own
organization yes in our own organization
uh well ladies and gentlemen is true you
can't trust anyone paranoia is your
friend uh as it turns out one of the
Three core training tenants right there
along with mandatory cui training from
the dod and some kind of basic cyber
security training as Insider threat
training that means like that guy behind
the camera he could be super sketchy and
try to steal information so I gotta be
trained on recognizing when he's a bad
guy I'm pretty sure that's how it works
anyway but the good thing is he's a good
guy and I know that because I would just
never give him any information because
that's that's we're compliant that's how
it works
he's on a need to know basis
and he doesn't need to know much
just how to hit record you must provide
you must provide it to be compliant all
right now here's a hint there is some
good news here which is that the dod has
actually provide Insider threat training
for free yes something in this process
for free like our Awesome YouTube videos
smash the like button right now and give
us a subscribe really makes us happy and
we do we do it for free
could probably be doing something more
fun
not sure what this is pretty fun
I love talking about compliance just
like you love listening to the sweet
sweet sounds of my voice talking about
compliance
anyway uh yeah dods actually provided
Insider threat training for free right
out here on the internet which is pretty
cool uh now if you happen to be one of
our virtual compliance officer clients
first off you rock and you probably
already hit the Subscribe button so you
if you hit the Subscribe button right
now you'll be at least one step closer
to just having this whole thing done for
you but if you are one of our personal
compliance officer clients where we act
as your fractional compliance officer we
actually do this training live with our
clients and even have a pretty cool
cartoonized video version that is
shorter and much easier to digest so
there's some flexibility in delivery
here but no matter what it's a
compliance control so you got to do it
let's check out what the assessors are
looking for on this one and how to keep
them happy now two points they're
looking for number one determine if
potential indicators associated with
Insider threats are identified uh how
would we actually know if there was some
Insider threat that's a great question
right
um because of course you got to know how
to recognize it
a couple of things one is if you've been
through Insider threat training there's
a lot of information in there about how
to recognize the human element of
Insider threat training but for the
purpose of sort of giving more of a
demonstratable answer for a sample
answer here we can point to our seam
system believe it or not right our
security information event management
system uh the same solution provides
potential in indicators associated with
Insider threats and is monitored by the
I.T team right so the ITT monitors the
same solution maybe you've got accounts
that are weird that are logging in maybe
it's a co-worker stole the account who
knows what what it is but again the same
solution definitely can provide those
potential indicators uh associated with
Insider threat
now the second point is determinive
security awareness training on
recognizing and Reporting potential
indicators of Insider threat is provided
to managers and employees okay so hang
on step further is it provided to
managers and employees we tell people
hey look you know if it was us right
we're doing compliance recovery we want
all authorized users who can see cui who
work with cui they've got to be required
to go through government provided or
equivalent Insider threat training again
we've made a version of it that it's
much more digestible if you've ever seen
one of these government provided
trainings well to be honest they kind of
feel like a government provided training
and you get what you pay for right I
mean that's how it works so hey in on
call we work with defense contractors
just like you and we help you make
getting compliant not suck so if you've
had this DeForest nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped into your lap
like a seagull on a sunny day we can
teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps gray areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance as your
secret weapon to land more Defense work
with higher profit margins now that's
what becoming an on-call compliance hero
can do for you and if you're looking for
more help getting compliant our
compliance experts are always on call
for you visit cmfc complianceecrets.com
or check out the bio below for links to
get help right now if you love the
content we're putting out here for you
help us out with a big thumbs up on that
like button or even better smash the
Subscribe button do it right now it'll
make us smile to get the latest
compliance content as soon as compliance
nerds roll it out our compliance nerds
but by the time we're done with you
you'll be a compliance nerd too and
you'll love it until the next compliance
tip my friends stay safe and secure out
there and hit us in the comments below
to let us know what you'd like to know
more about when it comes to information
security and compliance I'll see you on
the next one
[Music]
all right